just still lingering
a little bit longer we started this part
of the conversation talking about you
know
did humans evolve to think did the human
brain evolve to think
implying is there like a progress to the
thing
that's always improving that's right we
never
yeah and so the answer is no but let me
sort of push back
but so your intuition is very strong
here not your
intuition the way you describe this but
is it possible there's a direction to
this evolution like
do you think of this evolution as having
a direction
like it's like walking along a certain
path towards
something so we you know uh what is it
uh the elon musk
said like uh the earth got bombarded
with photons
and then all of a sudden like a tesla
was launched into space or whatever a
rocket started coming like is there a
sense
in which even though in the like
within the system the evolution seems to
be this mess of variation we're kind of
trying to find
our niches and so on but do you think
they're ultimately when you zoom out
there is a direction that's strong
that does tend towards um greater
complexity and intelligence
no so i mean and i and again
what i would say is i'm really i'm
really just echoing
people who are much smarter than i am
about this
but see you're saying smarter i thought
it doesn't there's no
that i thought there's no smarter no i
didn't say there's no smarter i said
there's no direction
okay so i think the thing to say or
or what i understand to be the case is
that um
there's variation it's not unbounded
variation
and there are selectors there are there
are there are pressures that we'll
select
and so not anything is possible because
we live on a planet that has certain
physical realities to it right
and but those physical realities are
what constrain
the possibilities
the physical realities of our genes and
the physical realities of our
corporeal bodies and the physical
realities of
um uh you know the of life on
on this planet so what i would say
is that um there's no direction
um but uh
there is no it's not infinite
possibility
because we live on a particular planet
that has
particular statistical regularities in
it and
some things will never happen and so
though all of those things are
are interacting with um
[Music]
uh with our genes and so on and our
you know the physical nature of our
bodies to make some things more possible
and some things less possible look i
mean
humans have very complex brains but
birds have complex brains
and so do uh you know um
so do uh octopuses have very complex
brains
and all three sets of all three of those
brains
are are are somewhat different from one
another you know
bird birds some birds have very complex
brains some even have rudimentary
language they have no cerebral cortex
i mean they admittedly they have this is
um now lesson two right they have
is it lesson two or less than one let me
think no this is lesson one
they have um uh
they have the same neurons the same
neurons that
that in a human become the cerebral
cortex birds have those neurons
they just don't form themselves into a
cerebral cortex but i mean crows for
example
are very sophisticated animals they can
do a lot of the things that humans can
do in fact
all of the things that humans do that
are very special that seem very special
there's at least one other animal on the
planet that can do those things too
what's special about the human brain is
that we put them all together
so we learn from one another we don't
have to experience everything ourselves
we can
watch another animal or another human
experience something and we can learn
from that well there are many other
animals who can learn by copying
yeah that we communicate with each other
very very efficiently we have language
but we're not the only
animals who are efficiently efficient
communicators there are lots of other
animals who can efficiently
communicate like bees for example um you
know we cooperate really well with one
another to do grand things but there are
other animals that cooperate too and so
every
innovation that we have other animals
have two what we have
is we have all of those together
interwoven in this very complex dance
in a brain that is not
unique exactly but
that is you know it does have some
features that
make it useful that make it particularly
useful for us
um to do all of these things uh
you know to have all these things
intertwined so
you know our brains are actually the
last time we talked i
i i made a mistake because i said
um in my enthusiasm i said you know our
brains are
are not larger are relative to our
bodies our brains are not larger
um than um than other primates and
that's actually not true actually our
our brains relative to our body size is
somewhat larger so
an ape who's not a human that's not a
human
um their brains are larger than their
body sizes than
say relative to like a smaller monkey
and a human's brain is larger relative
to its body size than a than a gorilla
it's a good approximation of your um of
whatever of
of the bunch of stuff you that you can
shove in there
but well what i was going to say is but
our cerebral cortex is not larger
than what you would expect for a brain
of art of of
of its size so so relative to say an
ape like a like a gorilla or a chimp or
even
a mammal like a dolphin or an elephant
um you know our brains
our our cerebral cortex is as large as
you would expect it to be
for a brain of our size so there's
nothing
special about our cerebral cortex and
this is something i explain
in the book where i i say okay you know
like by analogy
um if you walk into somebody's house and
you see that they have a huge kitchen
you know you might think well maybe you
know maybe this is a place i really
definitely want to eat
dinner at because you know these people
must be gourmet cooks
but you don't know anything about what
the size of their kitchen means unless
you consider it in relation to the size
of the rest of the house
if it's if it's a big kitchen in a
really big house
it's not telling you anything special
right if it's a big kitchen in a small
house
then that might be a place that you want
to eat for you want to stay for dinner
because
it's more likely that that kitchen is
large for a special reason
and so the cerebral cortex of a human
brain isn't in and of itself special
because of its size however
there are some genetic changes that have
happened
in the human brain as it's grown
with to whatever size is you know
typical for
for the whole brain size right there are
some changes that do
give the human brain slightly
more of some capacities
they're not special but there's just
they just
you know we can do some things
much better than other animals and you
know correspondingly other animals can
do some things
much better than we can we can't grow
back limbs we can't lift 50 times our
own body weight well i mean maybe you
can but
i can't live 50 times yeah ants with
that regard are very impressive
and then you're saying with the with the
frontal cortex like that's
the size is not always the right measure
of
capability i guess so size isn't
everything
size isn't everything that's a quotable
you know people like it when i disagree
so let me disagree with you
uh on something or just like play
devil's advocate a little bit
so you've uh painted a really nice
picture that evolution doesn't have a
direction
but is it possible if we just ran earth
over and over again
like this video game that the final
result will be the same
so in the sense that we're eventually
there'll be an agi type hal 9000 type
system that just like flies
and colonizes nearby uh
earth-like planets and it's always will
be the same
and and the different organisms and the
different evolution of the brain
like it doesn't feel like it has like a
direction
but given the constraints of earth
and whatever this imperative whatever
the hell is running this
universe like it seems like it's
running towards something is it possible
that will always be the same
thereby it will be a direction
yeah i think you know as you know better
than anyone else that that answer to
that question is of course there's some
probability that
that could happen right it's not a yes
or no answer it's what's the probability
that that would happen and there's a
a whole um distribution
of possibilities so maybe we end up
what's the probability we end up with
exactly the same
uh complement of creatures um including
us
what's the likelihood that we end up
with you know
creatures that are similar to humans
that are but you know
similar in in certain ways let's say but
not exactly humans or
you know all the way to a completely
different
um distribution of of creatures
what's your intuition like if you were
to bet money what does that distribution
look like if we ran
earth over and over again i would say
given the um
you're now asking me questions that this
is not science this is not science so
but i would say okay well what's the
probability that um it's going to be a
carbon life form
probably high yeah but that's because i
don't know anything about
really fairness yeah you know i don't
i'm not i'm not really well versed
that um what's the probability that you
know so what's the probability that
the animals will begin in the ocean and
crawl out onto land
versus the other way versus the i would
say probably high
i don't know but you know but do i think
what's the likelihood that we would end
up with exactly the same
or very similar i think it's low
actually
i i wouldn't say it's low but i i would
say it's not it's not 100
and i'm not even sure it's 50 you know
i would say i i don't think that we're
here by accident because i think
like i said there are constraints like
there are some physical constraints
about earth
now of course if you were a cosmologist
you could say well the
the fact that the earth is if you were
to do the big bang over again
and keep doing it over and over and over
again would you still get the same
solar systems would you still get the
same planets would you know
would you still get the same galaxies
the same solar systems the same planets
you know i don't know but my guess is
probably not
um because there are random things that
happen that can again
send things in one direct you know make
one set of trajectories possible and
another set
impossible so um but i i guess my
my my if i were gonna
bet something money or something
valuable i would probably say
it's not zero and it's not a hundred
percent
and it's probably not even 50 so there's
some probability but
it will be similar that would be similar
but i don't think i just think there are
too many degrees of freedom there are
too many degrees of freedom
i i mean one of the real tensions in
writing this book
is to on the one hand there's some truth
in saying
that humans are not
special we are just you know
we're not special in the animal kingdom
all animals are
um well adapted if they're survived
they're well adapted to their niche it
does happen to be the case that our
niche
is large for any individual human
your niche is whatever it is but for the
species right we live
almost everywhere not everywhere but
almost everywhere on the planet
but not in the ocean and actually other
animals like bacteria for example have
us beat
miles you know hands down right so
we're by any by any definition
we're not special
we're just you know adapted to our
environment but bacteria don't have a
podcast
exactly exactly so that's the tension
right so on the one hand you know we're
not special animals we're just you know
you know particularly well adapted to
our niche on the other hand our niche is
huge
and we you know we don't just adapt to
our environment we add to our
environment
we make stuff up give it a name and then
it becomes real
and so no other animal can do that and
so
i think the the thing the way to think
about it from my perspective or the way
i
made sense of it is to say you can look
at
any individual single characteristic
that a human has
that seems remarkable and you can find
that in some other animal
what you can't find in any other animal
is
all of those characteristics together
in a brain that is souped up
in particular ways like ours is and if
you combine these things
multiple interacting causes right not
one
not one essence like your cortex your
big neocortex
but um which isn't really that big i
mean it's just
big for it this for your big brain for
the size your big brain
it's that it's the size it should be um
if you add all those things together and
they interact with each other
that produces some pretty remarkable
results
and if you're aware of that
then you can start asking
different kinds of questions about
what it means to be human and what kind
of a human you want to be
and what kind of a world do you want to
curate for the next generation of humans
so you i think that's the goal anyways
right it's just to
just have a glimpse of
instead of thinking about things in in a
simple linear way
just have a glimpse of the some of the
things that matter that seemed that
evidence
suggests matters to
the kind of brain in the kind of bodies
that we have
once you know that you can you can work
with it a little bit
you